[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans ce sky
échos le magazine qui vous racontent la
vie des acteurs économiques du
territoire de saint quentin en yvelines
dans cette émission nous allons plonger
dans le monde industriel saint
quentinois des entreprises spécialisées
dans la mécanique de haute précision et
qui vont bénéficier du soutien de la
région ile de france dans le cadre de
son plan de relance pour l'industrie
voici le sommaire du sixième numéro du
sky et une 5e édition 100 % numérique
dans le contexte de crise sanitaire le
sky business day a rassemblé 400
entreprises à travers mille rendez-vous
pour nouer des partenariats commerciaux
la région ile-de-france a détaillé son
programme relance industrie dans les
yvelines 16 entreprises soutenu à
hauteur de 10 millions 250 mille euros
parmi elles de pme industrielles saint
quentinois sgam et caam hui en cours et
mécanique ateliers de coignières enfin
découverte d'une innovation développée
au ski cube à green it i un système
numérique pour accompagner les
agriculteurs dans leurs activités
une solution développée par la start-up
cortix c'est le rendez vous pour les
entreprises afin de faire des affaires
le sky business dé sa cinquième édition
qui s'est déroulée le jeudi 26 novembre
en visioconférence un rendez vous
traditionnel pour le monde économique de
saint quentin en yvelines
écoutez le président de l'agglomération
jean michel fourgous et sa vice
présidente en charge du développement
économique
alexandra rosetti donc on a 400
entreprises qui sont connectés donc avec
nous il ya déjà 1000 rendez vous
d'affaires qui sont programmés donc
voilà tout ça va dans le bon sens ça
démontre qu'il ya toujours de
l'appétence pour faire des affaires
les entreprises ont vraiment besoin
d'eux
ce type de rendez vous il ya eu aussi
des animations diverses et des
webinaires des tables rondes toute la
journée avec une moyenne de 365
participation à ces diverses animations
donc il ya eu un côté prise de rendez
vous qui a bien fonctionné et puis les
animations aussi depuis le début de
cette émission nous sommes au sein de la
société mécanique ateliers de coignières
une entreprise spécialisée dans la
mécanique de précision
plus de 80% de son activité est réalisée
dans le secteur de l'aéronautique
cette pme de 26 collaborateurs et
dirigée par jorge da costa venez on va
le rejoindre
[Musique]
bonjour jorge da costa bonjour
en quoi consiste votre activité et
comment avez vous été impacté par la
crise sanitaire
alors notre société consiste à usiner
des pièces mécaniques
nous avons malheureusement été impactés
très fortement sur la crise sanitaire où
on nous a vendu même arrêté la
production pendant quinze jours le temps
de pouvoir pourri des solutions de
protection auprès de nos collaborateurs
et rassurer nos clients qu'on repartait
en production derrière avec les moyens
efficace on a perdu malheureusement 30%
de notre chiffre d'affaires
alors quelle pièce vous fabriquez par
exemple on fabrique des pièces
essentiellement sur le secteur
aéronautique qui vont directement pour
dassault aviation ou d'autres
équipementiers et ce sont des pièces
soit de structures ou des pièces autour
du moteur alors vous voyez
essentiellement des centres d'usinage
à commande numérique des tours à
commandes numériques et des machines à
découper fier alors ce sont des moyens
qui sont préparés en amont via des
logiciels de cfao et qui met les
programmes on simule en amont et après
on transforme les matières on les ajoute
on les punit manuellement toute façon
automatique
elles sont contrôlées par maud la bo de
contrôler après livrés aux clients vous
êtes un sous traitant de rang après on
travaille en direct quelques coups avec
gaz totale est que des grands donneurs
d'ordre
on leur assure la traçabilité des
produits la transformation de la feuille
des temps
vous retrouvez des casquettes de visée
laser ou en fait et des systèmes de
détection de nuit pour pouvoir observer
vous avez également des supports de
cartes électroniques on retrouve en fait
donc là c'est vraiment sur du
développement ou donc en fait après il
vient d'implanter la carte électronique
tous les connecteurs qui viennent se
connecter sur le sur le cadre et ça
vient directement comme si c'était un
rack d'une belle informatique
on sait très bien qu'un avion il peut
pas s'arrêter sur un parking si une
défaillance et que malheureusement il
peut y avoir des crachats ce moment donc
notre industrie un vrai rôle aujourd'hui
de soutien aux fabricants de ces
produits dans le secteur aéronautique
la région vous a sélectionné pour
obtenir une subvention de 450 mille
euros à quoi va servir cette enveloppe
est est-ce que c'est complémentaire d'un
investissement que vous allez faire vous
même alors oui ça va être
complémentaires nous on va engager à 1
investissement de passe du million
d'euros qui va permettre de moderniser
notre outil de production de
correspondre entre guillemets au
standard de demain de lusine 4.0 ou les
gros donneurs d'ordre ou vont attendre
de leurs fournisseurs ce positionnement
donc en fait vous allez développer votre
vos outils qui sont déjà présents ici
c'est tout à fait on va compléter nos
outils aujourd'hui qui sont déjà
opérationnels on va les automatiser avec
des robots ou avoir acheté des machines
qui sont eux déjà complètement équipée
en en robot et on va essayer de
standardiser cette façon de faire mais
aujourd'hui on va essayer de se
reconvertir sur le secteur ferroviaire
ou ou militaires ou peut-être automobile
merci georges da costa vous en prie
merci à vous d'être venu nous rencontrer
les dirigeants de mécanique ateliers de
coignières et maintenant prenons la
direction de guyancourt au sein de la
société games et qu'à cette société a
aussi obtenu une aide de la région pour
accélérer la digitalisation de son
activité et acquérir de nouveaux marchés
[Musique]
nous sommes situés devant l'entreprise
game etc à guyancourt une société de 18
collaborateurs engagés dans la
fabrication de pièces de prototypes dans
le secteur de l'automobile et du pétrole
venez on va rencontrer isabelle chaillot
sakho dirigeante
bonjour
bonjour il avait le maillot bonjour
il
alors qu'est ce qui se passait bien mais
qu'est ce que vous faites concrètement
au quotidien alors de se spécialiser
dans la mécanique de précision nous
fabriquons des pièces sa façon selon des
plans dans des matières différentes que
ce soit du métal ou plastique plutôt
dans les secteurs de l'automobile du cac
alors que travaillant dans les secteurs
de l'industrie avec les grands acteurs
de l'automobile
du pétrole de la r&d également de
l'aéronautique et
avec des start up dans lequel nous
faisons confiance alors des secteurs que
vous avez mentionné ces des secteurs qui
ont été très impacté par la crise
sanitaire
comment vous l'avez ressenti vous ici
écoutez là c'est vrai que la fia nous a
beaucoup affectés
nous anticipons une grosse baisse d'ici
la fin de l'année entre -20 à -30%
c'est une crise qui est durable mais
nous espérons vraiment
rebondir l'année prochaine et nous avons
nous avons travaillé sur en interne de
nouveaux axes stratégiques des axes
stratégiques qui vont être accompagnés
par la région ile de france puisque dans
le cadre de son plan de relance
industrie la région ile de france vous
accorde une subvention de 350 millions
euros oui tout à fait donc on souhaite
justement remercier la région ile de
france qui va nous accompagner dans les
annes trois années qui viennent sur le
développement et les investissements de
la société
nous avons deux axes forts en terme de
bats stratégiques c'est-à-dire que
premièrement nous avons décidé de revoir
notre stratégie est d'investir moment
dans l'est dans les industries fort
notamment tout ce qui est industries
médicales et pharmaceutiques tout ce qui
a boosté agroalimentaire on voudrait
également se développer l'amplifier
industrie
verte notamment dans l'hydrogène mais
également dans tout ce qui est armements
et défense est également accompagné les
stars pop dans le puits ce qui est
robotique l' axe de développement
l'autre c'est vraiment d'investir dans
le numérique puisque on voudrait devenir
un des leaders dans notre industrie 4.0
non seulement dans tout ce qui est un
outil industriel de pointe mais
également accompagné par des
recrutements le personnel ils sont plus
investir dans les jeunes de demain qui
puisse accompagner
développement de l'industrie merci
isabelle chaillot co dirigeante de
l'entreprise gamme et cas située à
guyancourt
[Musique]
une découverte dans ce sky écho d'une
solution qui mêle agriculture et
technologies son nom à green it i une
application qui permet d'accompagner les
agriculteurs dans leurs interventions et
qui a été développée au ski cube
rencontre avec son créateur olivier
rocheau dirigeants de relance
[Musique]
on
le
[Musique]
je m'appelle olivier rocheau j'ai 49 ans
j'ai fondé la société otx en février
2010 9,1 pour bientôt deux ans on est
installé dans les locaux de ski cube à
guyancourt
orth x c'est une société qui développe
des solutions numériques pour l'usagé
des agriculteurs
[Musique]
à grigny qui c'est une solution qui
s'appuie sur un équipement embarqué dans
la cabine des tracteurs des engins
motorisés
associé à un équipement électronique
posées sur les outils qui vont permettre
de déterminer automatiquement la nature
des activités réalisées par
l'agriculteur les parcelles sur
lesquelles ils le font et les matériels
qu'ils utilisent
de cette manière on va déterminer sans
aucune saisie ce que l'agriculteur est
en train de faire de façon à répondre à
une obligation de traçabilité notre part
a gagné tu y vas interagir avec le
chauffeur avec l'agriculteur dans sa
cabine directement quand il aura besoin
d'informations complémentaires sur cette
activité à green it i c'est que
l'agriculteur est en train de sonner
il sait dans quelle parcelle et il va
demander à l'agriculteur la nature la
mairie attaquée en professionnel
[Musique]
notre actualitté c'est le lancement
commercial de la résolution ont l'âme
tests sur le terrain maintenant depuis
juin 2019
donc elle est pénalisée à l'épreuve
pendant plus d'un an ça nous a permis de
la mettre au point de la compléter de
voir quels étaient les attentes des
agriculteurs et on a terminé cette phase
de prototypage une réalisation pour
aboutir à une solution commerciale qui
est maintenant disponible depuis le mois
d'octobre avec une première
commercialisation au travers du
groupement ou avec lequel on a signé
donc le groupe noria ben qui propose
aujourd'hui en avant-première à green it
i à ses adhérents
c'est la fin de cette émission merci de
l'avoir suivi émission à revoir en
replay sur notre site internet ou sur
l'application mobile
à bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]